I can see why I liked your mom hold on  y'all know we're gonna walk by in the  morning  so Zimmerman laid eyes upon V McGuire  Niagara Falls detectives are  investigating a brutal attack on a local  woman and her 12 year old daughter  you're the only witness I need your help  [Music]  the economy this is a confused and  frightened child lying or whose mother  was so darryl act as a parents to drag  her to a drunken orgy party but it  wasn't rape it was consensual they are  completely innocent why would they do  that  do you just like I did  they have a document in this country  it's called the Constitution what's not  in that document is vigilante cop  justice who knows you might even need my  services so well and I hope you never  know more like that  I had a purpose to discharge my sworn  duty as an officer of the law  you